[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem freitag die vom sport hat norbert
lehmann
und das sind die wichtigsten themen von
heute
wird die krise zum krieg während
beunruhigende nachrichten aus der ost
ukraine kommen suchen politiker und
diplomaten in münchen nach einem ausweg
aus der verfahrenen lage
der gesundheitsminister waren zwar sei
der höhepunkt der omicron welle
überschritten so karl lauterbach mit der
pandemie könne man aber noch für zehn
jahre zu tun haben
der sturm tobt schon jetzt wirbeln die
orkanböen england durcheinander
deutschland wappnet sich für die
kommende nacht
der konflikt zwischen russland und dem
westen spitzt sich weiter zu immer
beunruhigende meldungen kommen aus dem
osten der ukraine
der vom prorussischen separatisten
kontrolliert wird dort flammen trotz
waffenruhe immer mehr gefechte auf in
bonn jetzt explodierte am abend eine
autobombe die separatisten haben
angekündigt die bevölkerung nach
russland zu evakuieren die regierung in
kiew bezichtigt moskau der provokation
und ruft die internationale
staatengemeinschaft zu einer antwort auf
christiansen
trümmerteile auf der straße sie stammen
von einem explodierten auto geparkt war
das fahrzeug das dem chef der volks
miliz gehören soll neben dem
regierungsgebäude in donetsk verletzt
wurde niemand schon am nachmittag
fliegeralarm im separatisten gebiet die
anführer der selbsternannten
volksrepublik in donetsk und lohans
warnen vor allem angriff des
ukrainischen militärs
der präsident der ukraine seelands die
wird in der nächsten zeit an die
militärs den befehl erteilen den plan
für den einmarsch auf das territorium
der volksrepublik bonn jetzt und lohans
zu realisieren beweise legt puschel ihn
dafür nicht vor und genau vor diesem
szenario war immer wieder gewarnt worden
dass der krieg in der ost ukraine neu
entfesselt wird durch an den angeblichen
ukrainischen angriff oder anschlag
die ukrainische regierung in kiew weist
die vorwürfe einmal mehr entschieden
zurück währenddessen kommt auch aus
moskau eine alte forderung wladimir
putin fordert bei einem treffen mit dem
belarussischen diktator lukaschenko die
ukraine auf direkt mit den separatisten
im donbass zu verhandeln was kiew
entschieden ablehnt
kiew muss sich mit vertretern des
donners an den verhandlungstisch setzen
und sich auf politische militärische
wirtschaftliche und humanitäre maßnahmen
zur beendigung des konflikts einigen je
früher das geschieht desto besser leider
sehen wir im moment das gegenteil einer
verschärfung der situation im dorf
und in moskau tut man so als habe man
damit nichts zu tun am abend wurden die
ersten kinder weg gebracht aus dem jetzt
nach rostov am don in südrussland
fragen wäre unsere korrespondenten in
moskau und kiew axel sturm wie schätzen
die menschen in der ukraine die lage ein
fast schon frühlingshaften tag dann ist
von anspannung und von panik überhaupt
nichts zu sehen und zu spüren oder mit
den menschen spricht die sind alle sehr
gefasst es gab heute vormittag auch die
veröffentlichung einer umfrage nach der
über 62 prozent der menschen in der
ukraine keinen militärischen konflikt
mit russland antizipieren aber die
situation wären es eben im beitrag
gesehen ist natürlich brandgefährlich
weil ganz viele informationen kursieren
wahnsinnig viele in den letzten acht 40
stunden die alle nicht überprüfbar sind
und sowohl separatisten als auch die
ukraine zeigen mit dem finger auf die
andere partei die osze die die
zwischenfälle in dieser region
kontrollieren soll die meldet in ihrem
bericht fast viermal mehr verstöße gegen
die waffenstillstands gegen das
waffenstillstandsabkommen als im
vergleichbaren zeitraum zuvor und viele
viele explosionen also brandgefährliche
situationen gefüttert mit vermutlich
auch desinformationen wir müssen
abwarten wie es weitergeht
fragen wir nach den signalen aus moskau
christiansen die gefechte in der ost
ukraine die ankündigung von raketentests
morgen setzt moskau oft provokation
man muss das also verstehen ja
deeskalation sieht auf jeden fall anders
aus man hat sich hier entschieden weiter
in den konfrontationen modus zu gehen
obwohl das hier offiziell niemand sagen
würde denn mit dem manöver morgen dem
neuen manöver hat der kreml offiziell
überhaupt kein problem und sieht er auch
gar keine neue provokation das große
neue manöver morgen wird auch persönlich
verfolgt von wladimir putin und er hat
sich dafür noch unterstützung holt der
belarussische diktator lukaschenko ist
seit heute zu gast in moskau die beiden
haben heute gesprochen und werden sich
gemeinsam morgen das manöver ansehen und
die botschaft die von dem manöver und
von moskau aus dann ausgehen soll wie es
auch relativ eindeutig denn wie heißt
eigentlich folgendermaßen russland kann
auf seinem territorium machen was es
will das militär ist stark und lukas
schenk und putin sind weiter sehr gute
freunde dankeschön christiansen und axel
sturm
die sicherheitskonferenz in münchen
startete heute ohne russland zum ersten
mal seit jahren ein zeichen wie ernst
die lage ist gefährlicher als im kalten
krieg sagt un-generalsekretär gut aus
münchen berichtet stefan leifert
auf den zentimeter genau haben sie den
abstand gemessen denn die teilnehmer
voneinander halten sollen trotz der
strengen corona vorkehrungen versuchen
eu und nato in münchen ihr zusammen
rücken zu demonstrieren angesichts des
drohenden kriegs in der ukraine
heute das müssen wir so deutlich sagen
droht ein neuer krieg mitten in unserem
europa russland spricht mit seinem
truppenaufmarsch einer absolut
inakzeptabel drohung aus erneut
verbreitet der kreml bilde von
vermeintlich abziehenden russischen
truppen aus dem grenzgebiet zu kräne auf
der sicherheitskonferenz wollen sie der
botschaft vom russischen rückzug aber
keinen glauben schenken wie der nato
generalsekretär im heute-journal
interview bekräftigt
es gibt überhaupt keinen zweifel dass
wir dort die höchste konzentration an
militärkräften seit dem kalten krieg
haben das ist weit mehr als eine übung
trotz der behauptung russlands es habe
kräfte abgezogen das ist nicht passiert
im gegenteil wir beobachten zusätzliche
kräfte die in richtung grenze gebracht
werden darunter truppen die teil eines
angriffs wären
kurz vor eröffnung der
sicherheitskonferenz kündigt der kreml
neue militärmanöver an die putin sogar
persönlich beaufsichtigen werde
ich bin tief besorgt über die hohen
spannungen und zunehmenden spekulationen
über einen militärischen konflikt in
europa ich glaube noch immer es wird
nicht passieren aber wenn es passiert
wäre es katastrophal
russlands regierung selbst ist nicht in
münchen vertreten erstmals seit jahren
ein unmissverständliches zeichen dafür
wie ernst die lage ist
ja eine klinik in münchen welche
optionen hat der westen jetzt was wird
in münchen diskutiert
es ist natürlich ein großes manko dass
die russische delegation mitsamt
außenminister lavrov in diesem jahr
abgesagt hat vordergründig weil es im
vorfeld der konferenz zu viel kritik an
russland gegeben habe wahrscheinlicher
aber ist dass außenminister lavrov wenig
lust hatte ziemlich allein der geballten
stimme des westens gegenüber zu setzen
dadurch zwingt er den westen auch dazu
ganz mit sich selbst zu diskutieren
gleichzeitig gucken die
konferenzteilnehmer natürlich auch in
die ost ukraine beobachten die
ereignisse dort annalena baerbock die
deutsche außenministerin hat heute in
ihrer eröffnungsrede noch einmal
russland aufgefordert einzulenken und an
den verhandlung tisch zurückzukehren zu
deeskalieren
andernfalls werde der westen geschlossen
sanktionen beschließen die auch die
gaspipeline nord stream 2 betreffen also
von hier aus münchen eher ein signal der
besorgnis als eins der hoffnung
dankeschön an der glienicker aus münchen
jetzt zum wetter das sturmtief ihr lena
ist gerade erst durch schon wütet das
nächste besonders heftig soll es in der
nacht an den küsten im norden und osten
werden die bahn stellt nach und nach den
zugverkehr ein in den niederlanden und
belgien starben drei menschen durch den
sturm und auch in großbritannien gab es
mindestens einen toten pablo solon ag
hat details
mit fast 200 stundenkilometern trifft
sturm junis auf die britische küste die
stärkste böe jemals im vereinigten
königreich gemessen wurde
der stolz der jahrtausendwende der
millennium dome in london verliert sein
dach flugzeuge geraten bei der landung
in heathrow ins trudeln und in london
wird erstmals die höchste warnstufe rot
ausgerufen
in den niederlanden hat der orkan erste
todesopfer gefordert und
auch deutschland steht eine stürmische
nacht bevor am späten abend soll es
besonders heftig werden mit bis zu 160
stundenkilometern soll sturm sehr nett
wie er hierzulande heißt über die
küstengebiete hinwegfegen die feuerwehr
warnt es besteht auch hier lebensgefahr
bleiben sie nach möglichkeit zu hause
die wahrscheinlichkeit dass ein baum
umstürzt er möglicherweise dadurch
menschen gefährdet auf oder vor fahrende
pkw stürzt ist einfach sehr sehr am real
sehr starke geben und auch die deutsche
bahn reagiert stellt den verkehr in den
betroffenen gebieten komplett ein wie
hier in hamburg wissen viele gestrandete
nicht wie es weitergeht
sturm geht um 17 uhr los also kommen
fahre ich jetzt nach hause und es läuft
schon nichts mehr die menschen in
norddeutschland bereiten sich auf eine
unruhige nacht vor
holen wir uns die einschätzung unserer
wetter expertin katja hornuf guten abend
katja was genau kommt da auf uns zu sehr
viel wind wir haben eben schon von den
160 kilometer pro stunde gehört die wir
über der nordsee erwarten und in der
zweiten nachthälfte gibt es dann
windgeschwindigkeiten von bis zu 140
kilometer pro stunde an der ostsee aber
eben vor allen dingen auch im binnenland
schwere sturmböen und orkanartige
sturmböen das ist wirklich ungewöhnlich
das gute ist morgen vormittag ist der
orkan dann aus deutschland weggezogen
ist es jetzt ganz normales winterwetter
oder doch eher außergewöhnlich das ist
außergewöhnlich stunden gibt es in
deutschland immer mal aber dass
innerhalb von nur zwei tagen gleich zwei
orkane fast drei viertel deutschland
betreffen das ist ungewöhnlich der eine
oder die andere erinnert sich vielleicht
noch an 1990 als vivian und wiebke ende
februar die haben auch mal in kurzer
zeit sehr viele milliarden schäden
gebracht aber das hier was wir jetzt
erleben ist wirklich extrem
außergewöhnlich ok also heute noch
besser zu hause bleiben dankeschön katja
oliver
nächstes wichtigstes wichtiges thema die
korona lage
bundesgesundheitsminister lauterbach
sieht den höhepunkt der omicron welle
überschritten warnte heute aber auch wir
sind noch nicht wirklich in sicheren
gewässern und auch für die krankenhäuser
will das lka noch keine entwarnung geben
patrizia wiedemeier hat mehr
es ist wie so oft bei dieser fast
wöchentlichen pressekonferenz es gibt
viele schlechte und mal auch gute
nachrichten die gute zuerst
unsere daten deuten darauf hin dass der
höhepunkt der mikrowelle überschritten
ist die fallzahlen sind in den letzten
tagen bundesweit leicht gesunken aber
der scheitelpunkt bei den
intensivpatienten sei noch nicht
erreicht auch bei den todesfällen noch
kein rückgang und so die schlechten
nachrichten es werde auch künftig
weitere quellen geben wenn ich ehrlich
sagen soll ist es so dass ich davon
ausgehe dass wir noch sehr lange mit der
pandemie zu tun haben werden
das kann man wirklich in zeiträumen auch
von zehn jahren denken dringend nötig
sei daher dass mehr menschen geimpft
werden die bundesregierung hofft dabei
auf den so genannten tod impfstoff
nowaks der eher einem grippeimpfstoff
gleicht und vielleicht auch von
impfgegnern vor allem in
pflegeeinrichtungen akzeptiert wird und
für die einrichtungs bezogene
impfpflicht eingesetzt werden kann wir
erwarten also am 21
februar dass das am montag erwarten wir
1,4 millionen dosen des
impfstoffes in der woche darauf nochmal
eine million und somit bekämen die
länder auf der grundlage
bevölkerungsgröße bekämen sie dann also
den impfstoff zugeteilt und noch eine
gute nachricht gab es dann am schluss
anfang nächster woche sollen endlich
details für den seit langem
versprochenen pflege bonus vorgelegt
werden
wie kommt afrika mehr impfstoffe das
wird seit langem diskutiert heute hieß
es auf dem eu afrika gipfel in brüssel
sechs afrikanische länder sollen zugang
zur m rna technologie erhalten um damit
selbst produzieren zu können
bislang musste afrika 99 prozent aller
impfstoffe importieren gegen das corona
virus sind nur knapp 12 prozent der
afrikanischen bevölkerung vollständig
geimpft in der eu sind es mehr als 70
gunnar krüger berichtet ein gipfel zwei
kontinente kennenlernen nach fünf jahren
pandemie aus europa und afrika brauchen
sich und streiten doch gerade wenn es um
profit geht und um die baupläne von m
rna impfstoffen
regierungen die wirklich wollen dass die
ganze welt zugang zu impfstoffen bekommt
sollten sich für eine freigabe der
patentrechte einsetzen
angesprochen ist auch deutschland doch
das bremst eine freigabe werde die
niedrige impfquote nicht erhöhen wenn
afrikanische länder wie hier in kapstadt
den impfstoff nachbauten dann müssten
sie geistiges eigentum property rights
es geht ja darum sicherzustellen dass
wir den großen fortschritt der zum
beispiel mit der entwicklung der
technologie verbunden das jetzt nicht
verspielen und der hat natürlich etwas
damit zu tun dass
bereits auch bewahrt bleiben darum packt
bei und tag lieber eine impfstoff fabrik
in container produziert damit in afrika
behält er bei den bauplan die eu
kommission wollte mehr
licht zur lizensierung und stark
eingeschränkten profiten das könnte die
brücke sein über die wir zusammen
doch im abschlussdokument bleibt der
technologietransfer freiwillig das
wiedersehen mit den europäern für viele
afrikaner eine enttäuschung
zu einem drama vor der griechischen
insel korfu nach dem brand auf einer
fähre gelten elf menschen als vermisst
das feuer war am frühen morgen
ausgebrochen die meisten der 200 91
passagiere und besatzungsmitglieder
konnten mit rettungsbooten in sicherheit
gebracht werden zwei lkw fahrer waren im
laderaum eingeschlossen erst am abend
wurden sie mit einem hubschrauber
gerettet jetzt
unser täglicher blick zu den
winterspielen norbert heute keine
deutsche mit annika auch nicht im
biathlon da gab es heute den massenstart
der frauen und der männer und in beiden
wettbewerben liefen die deutschen am
podest vorbei die männer mit einer
insgesamt enttäuschenden biathlon bilanz
in peking dabei lagen philipp nawrath
und benedikt doll zur hälfte des
abschließenden massenstartrennen es noch
aussichtsreich auf den rängen 2 und 4
schossen sich aber dann im
stehendschießen bei zeitweise starken
windböen mit sechs und sieben fehlern
aus den medaillenrängen am ende wurde
doll achter und nawrath
dreiundzwanzigster dabei bleiben die
deutschen männer erstmals seit 2010 tone
medaille bei olympischen spielen es
gewann der norweger johannes kohl vor
dem schweden martin konzil und dem
norweger webmaster christiansen starker
wind auch herausfordernd bei den
biathletinnen beste deutsche franziska
preuß als im ziel die deutschen
biathletinnen sind mit ihrer peking
bilanz einmal gold einmal bronze
zufrieden siegerin die französisches
team brescia boucher ferte leck auf und
machte uns gehäuse land beide aus
norwegen
gute medaillenchancen haben die
deutschen frauen im zweierbob nach den
beiden ersten von vier läufen führt
laura nolte und vor sogar neuen
bahnrekord die 23 jährige und ihre
anschieberin haben eine halbe sekunde
vorsprung vor ihrer teamkollegin arianna
janka auf platz zwei morgen fällt die
entscheidung
china superstar einigen group feiert
ihren zweiten sieg und schreibt ein
stück olympia- geschichte nach gold im
big air und silber im slopestyle war sie
heute in ihrer spezial disziplin
halfpipe nicht zu schlagen damit landete
als erste freestylerin bei denselben
winterspielen dreimal auf dem podest
bittere heimpleite für den bvb die
dortmunder verloren gestern gegen die
glasgow rangers mit 2 4 nach der
champions league droht nun auch das aus
in der europa league nichts passte
zusammen in diesem spiel frust und
kritik sind groß nach dieser niederlage
hat nicht gut funktioniert standen nicht
kompakt wir waren keine einheit
unnötige zu einfache ballverluste
kennzeichneten wiederholt das dortmunder
spiel kurz nach der pause stand es
bereits 1 zu 4 dortmunds berlinger im
post immer wieder wollte sich nicht
abfinden mit dieser leistung ein schönes
tor gelang noch am ende aber steht die 2
4-niederlage sinnbildlich für diese
saison und eine verheerende
mannschaftsleistung dortmund muss
nächste woche in glasgow nun mit drei
toren unterschied gewinnen um das
europa-league-aus direkt abzuwenden
leipzig hatte immerhin gestern am gegen
san sebastian 1 2 2 unentschieden
geschafft ich danke bitte für den sport
wie es nach der orkan macht morgen
weitergeht sagt gleich katja horneffer
das heute journal um 10 mit marian
marietta slomka darin ein interview mit
nato-generalsekretär
stoltenberg passen sie auf sich auf
heute nacht ein schönes wochenende
wünschen wir ihnen und bis morgen wenn
sie mit auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend orkans in app ist bereits
angekommen seiner warmfront hat
deutschland bereits überquert und am
nachmittag kam dann auch die kaltfront
und brachte die ersten orkanböen mit zum
beispiel in gütersloh das kräftigste
windfeld ist aber hinter der kaltfront
und das sehen sie hier an diesen lila
feilen sie sehen wie sich das organ
windfeld über den nordwesten und den
norden deutschlands weiter wälzt in
richtung nordosten und morgen früh wird
es noch am längsten über rügen und
usedom sehr stürmisch sein und es gibt
noch weitere orkanböen aber dann wird
der tag doch deutlich ruhiger machen sie
sich heute nacht auf extreme orkan böen
an der nordsee gefasst mit
windgeschwindigkeiten bis
160 kilometer pro stunde bringen sie
sich in sicherheit sichern sie alle
losen gegenstände meiden sie wälder und
verschieben sie alle überflüssigen
reisen heute nacht gibt es kräftige
schauer und gewitter in norddeutschland
und morgen früh droht an der nordsee
eine schwere sturmflut am alpenrand kann
es etwas regnen und schneien bei 6 bis 0
grad und morgen wird es dann für viele
ein sehr freundlicher tag mit fünf bis
zwölf grad am sonntag gibt es dann
weitere regenfälle es wird auch windig
aber der orkan ist eindeutig vorbei
guten abend